how do we eliminate that outside noise  why not [ __ ] caring about other  people's opinions once and [ __ ] for  all high school is [ __ ] over stop  playing in it it's over you left in  eighth grade when you got a zit you were  like so [ __ ] petrified to go to  school i know that feeling and my point  to everybody is everybody's worried  about theirs it like when you come to  school nobody cares about yourself  they're worried about their zip yeah and  the person that actually would pick on  you for that they're in the worst spot  because they're so insecure that they're  gonna attack you first before you get to  that i think grown-ups just still play  in high school